i have to ask you about khabib so i
remember a while ago rogan said that uh
that's the perfect fight uh
yeah it could be you are
so let me ask two questions the first
do you think you can beat him in an mma
match when you're at your peak yeah i i
don't like uh yeah i mean it's one of
those people where people like will get
really mad at me if i say yes but yeah i
mean how would you do it how would you
solve that puzzle yeah uh
i mean we would grab one i think i would
be better than him but i you know i i
feel weird saying because people like
yeah i write your full [ __ ] you know and
but that's no no one out grappled them
right i mean nobody did and maybe i'm
wrong on this but i if we will get the
best possible candidates i'm definitely
one of them and then obviously i have a
small size advantage too
so in a wrestling match so we can just
reduce that mma match to a wrestling
match what do you think is the right
strategy on him like do you understand
his style that the
the his wrestling style the pressure he
applies do you understand how the hell
he makes it happen
yeah i mean he never unfortunately
fought any real who i would say really
really high level wrestlers i was
actually really disappointed how bad
justin gaich's wrestling was because
just engaged he had some solid success
but justin was really bad in that fight
um gate she had success
yeah i think he was seventh place
maybe or so somewhere he was definitely
all american uh it was lower though um
so yeah i would i would like to see how
he dealt with someone who was like who i
think oh man this guy's a really high
level wrestler because you know we saw
and this is early in his career but you
know grayson tebow did give him some
issues earlier in his career um
so i would like to see him in that
situation and see how he does i would
love to like you know i i just love
wrestling and grappling like yeah i'd
love it someone said hey ben
you know khabib wants to roll with you
okay i'm there tomorrow sounds like a
blast let's go
it's probably competitive as hell
yeah
you're still competitive i know when to
be and when not to be like you know say
if i'm going to high school kids are
not going to be competitive because
then i'm just being a dick how would you
take him down
what what i'm a real wrestler like
wrestling wrestling wrestling wrestling
i would probably try to text single eggs
and stuff sing likes yeah
i haven't okay
no no i mean i know
don't have the slightest clue i'd have
to feel i'd feel them out um but single
leg's my best taking people talk about
his wrestling being really good the
people that trained with him so okay so
i i grilled someone i will not say who
on the ed ruth think ed ruth is very
elite at folk style wrestling he never
became that great at fighting
unfortunately wait ed ruth wrestled
could be they were on the same team for
a while yeah okay and there was rumors
that could be beat him up and i said i
sure can't believe that and i've heard
that that was
if they were just straight wrestling ed
would get slightly the better of it well
edwards is like one of the greats he's
great he's really good yeah
so that was what i heard
but in an mma setting because of all the
tools that khabib would get him
i don't know
but it what but i agree i agree with
rogan on this one that would have been
good to see yeah i'm fine so yeah kabib
wants to work out i'd love it i love i
love wrestling and grappling i don't do
much juju because i don't have time for
it anymore i'm at the wrestling academy
like every single day
uh but yeah i i love jiu jitsu while i
did it and you know if i didn't have
wrestling cameras i probably would still
be doing
you